Thank you
you so much for having me.
Google.
I'm really honored that y'all showed
up during your lunch break. Very cool.
And for those in the audience
who haven't read the book,
can you summarize what
it's about? Sure. So, um,
the book breaking cover is
a memoir and it's about, um,
it answers all the key questions. Like
how in the world did you get into the CIA?
Uh, it talks about my career
at the CIA, which was, um,
being an undercover counterterrorism
officer along with my husband.
We served together for 10 years,
uh, primarily in the Middle East.
And then also follows us after we leave
the agency and what we did afterwards.
So it's a memoir. And, um,
the whole point of the book is to
use my story to inspire others.
Uh,
cause I'm from a small town in Florida
and I come from a very rural area and I
never imagined myself doing anything
remotely like the CIA. And, um,
I eventually found out that um,
ordinary people can do really
extraordinary things when
you don't let your fear
get in the way.
And that's the point of the bike.
How did you go from being someone who
wanted to become a ballerina to actually
becoming an expert with counter
terrorism and at CIA? Yeah,
so people will say,
they just assume like,
you must've grown up wanting to
be a spy. I'm like, really? No.
Um, I wanted it to be a
Rockette or a ballerina.
And,
um,
but instead I actually found myself
being very fascinated by foreign affairs,
um,
because of National Geographic magazine.
I love National Geographic.
And so as a kid introduced me to a world
completely outside of anything I knew
from central Florida and I
eventually followed that passion,
um,
to the Middle East for study
abroad programs in college.
And then I went to Georgetown for my
masters and Arab Studies and got recruited
out of Georgetown and to the CIA.
In the book you talk about, uh,
your mentor who wouldn't even make eye
contact with you because of your gender
and would only address your
male colleague in the room.
How did you deal with that? Okay. So here,
here you are. You're from a small town,
you've been offered a job in the CIA,
but now you've got to go through
a year's worth of training,
which is kind of like bootcamp for
intelligence officers. And so I had,
I totally had imposter syndrome.
How in the world did I get hired
into the CIA? What am I doing here?
Am I capable of this job?
And so during that year of training,
because you're learning a trade craft,
it's very intense.
And so you're,
you get placed with a mentor.
So there's one mentor and to students.
And so it was a male, a male student,
and myself,
and this guy was a legend at the CIA.
And on the first day in the little
tiny office where we were meeting,
he introduced himself and,
and um,
I realized he was only talking to
my male colleague the whole time.
He couldn't even look at me. And
I was like, that's really weird.
And, uh, after, after we were
done with that hour long session,
my male colleague said, well, that was
strange. And I said, did you notice that?
He goes, yeah, he didn't look at you once.
And eventually it came out that this
gentleman who had already been retired for
about 20 years had only worked with women
and the context and being secretaries
and the agency and he could not conceive
of the idea of a female being an
intelligence officer. And he just
couldn't wrap his brain around that.
And so I realized in that
moment, you know, that, okay,
so I guess I'm going to have to deal
with being a little bit invisible,
but you got to do what you gotta do.
How do you transition something that
can be a perceived weakness into an
advantage?
So I decided in that moment like,
I can't help what this
guy thinks about me. Um,
he has his own preconceived ideas of
what women may or may not be capable of.
And he kept saying things to me like,
are you sure you want to work
in the Middle East? And I
kept saying, yeah, I mean,
I've actually spent a lot of time already
in the Middle East and I'm fascinated
by this culture. And he said, but
you know, it's dangerous. And I said,
I'd get that any,
he admitted to me one day that he
could not envision me carrying out
clandestined operations on behalf
of the CIA as a, as a woman.
But I just decided like, okay, um,
there's nothing I can do about that,
so I'm just going to learn everything
I can from him and just push past it.
So like there are places like
I'm sure a company like Google,
if you perceive a systematic issue or a
problem, you can address that officially,
but the agency is not one of those places.
So I just had to like put up with it.
I'll show him eventually.
And it's interesting because I remember
there was a part of the book where you
talk about it's the HR department
that decides to place people at,
especially women at desk jobs
and it's intentional. Yeah, it's,
it's an intentional
decision. Uh, at the agency,
certain positions they, uh, they would
like women to be in primarily, uh,
when you're talking about field
positions being deployed overseas in the
clandestine service,
um,
there's a case officer role and they
tend to like having men in that role,
particularly in the Middle East region.
And then there's one that's
more behind the desk, uh,
that's managing the flow of intelligence.
And so they put me in that position
and they said, your husband,
who's a native speaker of Arabic,
he,
he can do this field role much
better than you as a female.
And I was like, okay,
well they're the CIA.
They must know because they kept saying,
these guys are not going to respect you.
Um,
the kind of sources that we're dealing
with are very hardened terrorist and
insurgents and you're just never gonna
be able to do this job. And so I,
I thought, well, this CIA must know.
And when I got to Baghdad
in my third deployment,
I'm and in the field,
and I'm seeing that my,
my male colleagues other than my husband
and a couple others had never been to
the Middle East. And it suddenly
dawned on me, wait a minute,
how can these people do a better job
than I can when I've been busting my butt
to study the Middle East? And I, and I
know this culture really, really well.
And it,
and I finally realized him in Baghdad
when I finally got into the debriefing
room that the CIO is wrong. But it took
me a really long time to figure it out.
And
unfortunately, this is not
just at CIA is, you know, um,
we all deal with it in various
forums. Um, a lot of my friends, uh,
not just in the tech field, but even
outside, uh, they get to control.
You'd have the biases and they decide
to leave the workforce. How have you,
um, ever felt like doing that?
And if so, what made you,
you know,
what kept you going?
So I,
I would be lying if I said that I
didn't consider leaving the CIA about a
thousand times. There was a
really hard career and, um,
but I'm also a very stubborn person,
so if somebody tells me I can't do
something or I'm told I'm not good enough,
or, um, I'm pushed aside,
there's something deep inside me that
just wants to prove everybody wrong.
And so I think that determination to win,
just what kept me in
there kept me in the role.
Based on your experience,
what advice would you give to a woman
who feels somewhat marginalized and their
role?
Yeah,
so it's really tough to be completely
underestimated all the time.
And,
but at the same time it can be useful,
especially in the agency
when you're dealing with like
counter terrorism issues.
There were a lot of,
uh,
experiences in which it was
good to be underestimated.
So meeting with special cases where they
thought we could be dealing with double
agent. And so what was really
useful as walking to a meeting, uh,
an individual from a different culture,
some were from the Middle East,
somewhere from different cultures who
essentially thought that I didn't know
anything. And so that
I use that to my, um,
my advantage and there was meetings and
so I would get people to open up to me
not realizing what they were doing.
So being underestimated.
You can't help what other
people think about you.
You have no control over what's
going on in somebody else's mind.
But what you do have control over is the
extent to which you develop yourself to
a point you can no longer be ignored.
So all those years when people thought
I wasn't intelligent and couldn't
anything about Arab culture,
I put my head down and I decided to do,
to figure out how to do this job
better than anybody else. I mean,
they just decided I've got to figure
out how to be a really good intelligence
officer. And so I built up
this expertise over time,
a counterintelligence and
counterterrorism expertise.
Until finally the point at
which I demonstrated very
clearly that I could walk
into a debriefing room with an Arab stores
and get him to give me intelligence.
He wouldn't give other people.
And then finally,
I finally,
after years and years of building up this
knowledge could prove myself and then
I could use that leverage to get the kind
of job I wanted in the CIA, which was,
um, that special job looking at potential
double agents and things like that.
But it's a slow process.
It takes time to become an expert in
your field. But I would just say like,
do the best you can to become really
good at that thing you're most passionate
about and then make it so that people can
no longer ignore you because you're so
good at your job.
Um, this is a bit of a loaded
question though, I admit,
but do you think you would have ultimately
achieved more in your career if you
were a man?
I know that is a loaded
question. Um, I don't know.
And I guess I try not to think
of it that way. Um, I just,
I'm the eternal optimist.
So even when I'm up against something
that's a huge challenge. I just,
you know, I guess I feel like
eventually on the other end of this,
something good is going to work out.
And if I think back to what if I had
been a guy or what if this it just,
I guess I try not to think of it that way.
Um,
in the book you talk about how
sometimes being open and s,
you know,
smiling can be misconstrued as
a one dimensional and naive.
Um,
how did you deal with it?
Do you think that sort of assumption is
warranted and also does it make sense
for us to put up a tougher exterior?
Are you guys can tell just in a short
period of time you've been in this room
that I'm a fairly outgoing,
Smiley personality. Um,
I really enjoy interacting with people.
And so I have noticed,
especially in a environment
like Washington DC, um,
people assume that when nice and
friendly and open and smiley,
you are not,
um,
multifaceted that you're not intelligent.
And,
and it's not people being jerks,
they don't even really often understand
they're creating these ideas about you
in their head.
Um,
but I learned in DC and in the Middle
East how to show other aspects of my
personality at different times.
So I learned when I was in a
place like Cairo as a student,
I'm studying culture.
I learned how to stand up for myself
in situations where I was being taken
advantage of. You know, and that's
when the smile comes off your face.
And that's when you show the rougher part
where the more aggressive part of your
personality.
So coming from the south as a good
southern girl where you don't show when
something's wrong or you don't,
um,
you have to be very subtle in how you
approach people. When something's wrong.
It doesn't work in a place like
Washington or the CIA or the Middle East.
You have to find that.
You have to find ways to
reveal the multidimensional
nature of your personality.
So I can stand up for myself.
I can get aggressive when I need to.
Um,
and understanding and having
the confidence to do that
was something I learned
in the Middle East.
And earlier in the talk you mentioned
imposter syndrome and this is something
that's not, um, you know,
time to just, you know,
being a woman that it cuts across gender.
Um,
and you also talk about one of your male
colleague who also built with it. Uh,
how does one overcome imposter
syndrome? Yeah. Um, okay.
Has anyone in this room raise your hand
if you've ever dealt with the whole
imposter syndrome issue?
Okay.
I feel so at home right now.
Um,
that's so interesting cause I came to
Google thinking you guys all knew how
awesome you are all the
time. And Jasmine's like, no,
we feel it too. And so, um,
imposter syndrome,
I think there's something refreshing
about knowing that you're not the only
person who suffers that.
Okay.
So I get into the CIA. I've never
known anybody who worked at the CIA.
I've only seen it in Hollywood movies.
So in my mind,
people were prep their whole
lives to be CIA officers.
They're all martial artists with black
belts. They all speak five languages,
they're all total cultural
savant who traveled the world.
And so you walk in there all meek and
mild and thinking, you know, I'm not sure,
I'm not sure I can do this.
And then you discover how very wrong you
were and you look around you and you're
like, okay, these are just regular
human beings here in this building. Um,
the way that I dealt with
imposter syndrome is simply
by not quitting and much
of the time was just because
I was too embarrassed to quit.
And so sometimes I tell like
to tell people I've had a
lot of success in my life
simply just cause I hung in there longer
than other people with the secret to my
success.
Um,
and it's because I
think when you struggle,
when you work so hard to deal
with your imposter syndrome,
the process of that struggle breeds
something really beautiful in you in terms
of your expertise.
When I had a meeting and the guy sitting
across from me is telling me he's an l
Catia Amir and he's telling me he's
been running operations in Baghdad and
something about his body language is
telling me intuitively that it's that he,
there's something wrong with this guy.
And I sat in the struggle for weeks after
this debriefing trying to figure out
why is it bothering me, what about
this guy is giving me this bad feeling?
And after weeks of trying to go
through this debriefing in my head,
I suddenly realized this guy was
an acting like an l Cada Amir.
He wasn't behaving like all of the other
terrorist I had dealt with when they
walked in a room, these other guys,
they walked in like they own the place,
they had the biggest egos I
have ever seen in my life.
And it suddenly I was suddenly realized
this guy didn't have an ego and he was
scared.
And when I picked him up in my car,
I actually had a moment where I thought
this guy is going to pee his pants.
Like he was shaking like a leaf.
And after weeks of going back
through the entire meeting,
this struggle brought me
to a point where I said,
I don't think he's what he's telling us.
I don't think he's in Okada Mirror.
I don't even think he's in El Cada at all.
Nevermind being the
leader of a cell group.
And it turns out that after a couple of
months of intensive efforts for me to
vet his information,
he was never an all Cada.
And so that, that, that struggle,
it brought me to a place where
I suddenly had this confidence.
Like I can read body language,
I get the culture enough to
realize when something's wrong.
And then finally that whole
imposter syndrome thing,
it finally went away.
And it was like a turning point in my
career when I realized that I was actually
really good at intelligence.
So the moral of this story
is just hang in there.
You know how, uh, biocese
goes both ways, uh,
like how people judged you in Middle East.
Uh,
we tend to have all these stereotypical
ideas about people from at least as
well. Uh, but you have
spent a of time with them.
You know them on a personal basis,
what are some of the misconceptions
that we as Americans have against them?
So I mean the first thing is that,
um,
when you don't interact with it,
certain people group you tend to
have the worst ideas about them.
And the thing that I love about
people from the Middle East that I,
that you realize immediately when you
go to the Middle East is how hospitable
people are and how they will literally
give you the shirt off their back.
The way they treat visitors,
the way that they welcome you into their
home or welcome me to their country is,
um, I learned what
hospitality wise from Arabs.
And it taught me a lot about
being a better person. So that's,
that's one thing I like to tell people.
And another thing that makes me crazy
is when I hear people say things like,
Oh,
you served in the Middle East.
It's that place where people just
kill each other all the time.
And this has been going on for thousands
of years and it, and it sounds like, oh,
they're just animals over there and
they just love to fight. You know,
they're just warmongers.
And what makes me crazy about that is
it's a fundamental misunderstanding of the
Middle East.
There's a lot of identity politics
that exist in the Middle East that are
different than where we have in America.
Our political system here is very
different than the political system in the
Middle East. And so what you have, you
don't have separation of church and state.
They're integrated into one.
And so that creates a completely
different dynamic in terms of identity,
politics and fighting for
control over ideology,
which is fighting for control over power.
Um,
it's not because people aren't biting
each other because they just love warring
or they're just these animals is that
they're dealing with a different set of
political circumstances.
And in order to understand that,
you really have to look at and recognize
how different the systems are that
we're dealing with.
That's quite fascinating because most of
us hear about terrorism and terrorists,
you know, based on headlines that
we get, you know, through media,
but you know them as
people beyond criminals.
And um, and that is really
interesting. You know,
we don't get to see that
side of those people. The
most fun part of my job isn't
as an intelligence officer.
Everybody thinks of Hollywood.
You're driving fast cars,
you're drinking Martinis,
you're doing all this high speed stuff.
Um,
but what I find the most fascinating
aspect of being an intelligence officer is
the psychological aspect of those
interactions with another human being.
So the way I like to explain it is you
have created a relationship with a guy
who you have nothing in common with.
As a counterterrorism officer,
your job is to get insider.
You need to stop terrorist
attacks from occurring.
So who are you meeting meeting with?
You're going to be meeting with
penetrations of a terrorist group.
These are guys who have turned on the
rest of the terrorist group and have
agreed to be the mole.
They've agreed to risk their lives,
to partner with the CIA to
give you this intelligence.
So while he's a terrorist,
while he has clearly killed people,
he now is at a place that
he's willing to work with you.
If you mishandle his intelligence,
if you mishandle his identity information,
you could get him killed.
So he's risking his life
to be meeting with you.
So if I'm going to be interacting with
this human being to get intelligence out
of him,
fundamentally he has to trust me.
And if I walked through the door and I'm
the opposite of what he's expecting as
a female,
he's not going to trust me.
So how do I connect with this guy
who has crazy hard and ideology,
thinks nothing. Women should never
leave home. And if they leave home,
they should have be completely
covered and have a male escort.
How am I going to connect with him if
I want him to see me as a human being?
I have to understand who he is and
it's got to be something other than
terrorists sitting in a seat across from
me. He has strengths, he has weaknesses.
He has his own motivations.
And if I'm going to work
with him in intelligence,
I have to know what his motivations are.
Is He doing this for money?
Is he doing this to take
out the competition?
Is he doing this because he no longer
buys into the ideology and he's had it
with El Catia and he's willing to risk
his life to work against them. Um,
so fundamentally I,
I can't do my job unless I can see that
person and interact with them as a human
being. You say have the agent
who interacts with them,
they have three big challenges and then
you don't case you have the fourth one.
Um, do you want to elaborate
what those challenges are? Yeah.
See your challenges as you're trying
to then make this connection with this
person. You have s you know, hardly
anything in common with is, first of all,
you're an American,
so you're the enemy from the get go.
And we're talking about not all middle
easterners were talking about these
terrorists sources we're meeting with.
Then secondly,
you worked for the CIA,
so you're double enemy.
And then thirdly, it's assumed you're a
Christian if you're white, that doesn't,
it's obviously not necessarily the case,
but they assume that so you
are American, Cia, Christian,
and then female with soon.
It's like you have the deck
stacked against you and so
you'd have to figure out,
I was preparing for my first
debriefing in Baghdad. I realized,
okay, again, I can't help with that.
Guy Thinks of me when I
walked through the door,
but I've got to figure out very quickly
how to make this connection with him.
So I've got to take all of his assessments
about me and turn them on their heads.
I have to absolutely
turn them upside down.
And the reason why it's
got to happen quickly,
it's because we're getting
shelled constantly and there's a,
it's we're in the Green Zone and we've
got a curfew and we thought all of these
external things going on. So we have
got to make this meeting happen quickly.
So I walk in the room and I have to be
sure that my body language is exuding
confidence, even though I
am terrified, I'm excited,
I like I'm shaking, but I don't
want him to see that I'm shaking.
So I'm like deep breathing exercises.
I agree to him in Arabic.
I greet him using Arabic,
uh, freezes that show.
They're not like show Kieron off one.
Like thank you or you know, silly phrases.
I'm using phrases that demonstrate I've
studied Arabic and then I'm talking to
him about something that matters to him.
So I've studied this guy inside and out
and I know that the guy I'm meeting with
has this huge ego and he feels really
important. So I stroke his ego.
I say Abba,
Muhammad,
I am so impressed by what you
have done in the last few months.
You have been incredibly
brave by sharing x, Y, z.
What you have done is literally
pushed l Catia out of your village.
I'm really impressed with you.
So I'm stroking his ego.
I'm making him feel important because
we all want to feel important.
And then I got to show
him that I'm intelligent.
So I have to talk about Iraq writ large.
My knowledge of a rock,
what kind of a country or rock is,
I have to show him that
I know specifically how a
rock is different than the
rest of the Middle East.
What makes a rock unique?
And as I'm having this conversation
with him, this like back and forth,
nice to meet you in this,
this exchange,
I'm seeing his eyes like twitching
because I am not what he expected.
And so I know that it's working and so
I continue this dialogue with him and I
can see that I am shocking
the heck out of him.
And about five minutes into this exchange
where I have confronted every single
miss assessment, he has this
moment where he just decides like,
wow,
she's smart,
I like her and I'm going to work with
her and now we can get down to business.
And now I have taken my disadvantage as
a female and now I've turned it on his
head and now he wants to
impress me because I'm a female.
Fine. I can work with that if that's
how, if that's what we're dealing with.
Fine. And so I realized
that if you are, um, the,
anyone can use this strategy to deal
with people who don't fundamentally
understand who you are, but you
have to work with them nonetheless.
I'm going to switch gears a little bit.
Um,
there have been a lot
of shootings recently,
including one at our youtube campus.
Um,
is there something that we as civilians
can do to be more alert and stay safe?
Yeah, I know that's such
a tiny question. Question,
easy question you asked Jasmine.
Um,
so I think the most important thing is
to realize where you're most vulnerable
because some attacks were surprised like
this one, and you can't plan for that.
And you can't really prepare in many
situations for the lone wolf to,
to crack and do what this woman did.
However,
I do like to tell people it's really
important to know when you're most
vulnerable or to know when you're in
situations where if something's happened,
this might be a place
where it will happen.
So it tends to be in places where like,
um,
you're at a concert or you're
at a mall during Christmas time,
like buying presence in December where
you're in large gatherings of people,
you're at a sporting event.
Whenever you're in places like that,
you have to just say,
okay,
in this moment I realized that I
am in a place where this abuse,
we're just target rich
environment for a terrorist. Um,
but here's the other thing,
it's telling yourself ahead of time that
you're going to have the right response.
God forbid something happens
because when an attack occurs,
you have a surge of adrenaline that goes
to the courses through your body and
you have one of three reactions.
It's either fight,
flight or freeze.
And it sounds really basic but a lot
of people freeze and their situations
because they're so overcome by fear
or they don't know what's happening.
And so the idea is to tell
yourself ahead of time,
God forbid I am ever in one of those
situations, I am not going to freeze.
And so sometimes survival,
it's as simple as not freezing.
And this the ca gave us training because
a lot of us were sent to war zones and
places where we could be ambushed and
the idea is that the place where the
attack occurs is called the acts and you
have to do anything possible to get off
the ax and their situations so they
actually trained us find out where the
threat's coming from,
which direction and run the other way and
again it sounds really like really the
ca has to teach you people that but yes
they do and actually I think as human
beings just recognizing the potential
responses in being able to say like you're
taking your family out and you guys are
in a public place and you realize we
could be a little bit
vulnerable, vulnerable here.
Where are the exits? The exits.
So when I go to a concert, I look at the
concert hall and I already exit, exit,
exit, exit. Whereas everybody going
to go probably that direction.
Is there another direction I could
go to not get involved in a stampede?
These are the kinds of things
I think through my head.
Where's cover or concealment? If something
happened right now, where would I run?
And so it's a counterterrorism officer.
I am a little sick like that all the time.
But anyway,
it gives you an idea of what you can
think through in your head is you're
dealing with an attack, like what
just happened on your youtube campus?
How long did she have her weapon out?
Did she brand a shit for several seconds?
Did she give anybody a moment to respond
or does she literally just pull it out
and start shooting? So the
questions are, you know,
how much time do you have
and to just do anything.
I'm telling you guys anything
to get off the ax. That's,
that's actually a great advice.
Um,
as someone who has dealt with a
lot of people with ill intent, um,
can you even spot them in public?
Is it even possible? I mean,
once they pulled the gun out,
then of course, you know, um,
I think that you could be quite surprised
at how much you can see when you're
paying attention. Um, I was with my
family, this was during my CIA training.
So I started learning how to pay attention
to my surroundings at this period of
time.
And we were in a toy store and this book,
this story is actually in the
book, so you'll recognize that. Um,
but we were in a toy store and we're
walking down the aisle and I saw this guy
crouched down by the Barbie
dolls and he looked weird.
He looked unkempt,
like his hair was like not combed.
Like half of his shirt was tucked in.
He just looked super sketchy and he like
made the hair on the back of my neck
stand up.
And so I literally watched this guy's
eyes glom onto my six year old niece and
watch her walk down the aisle
in such an inappropriate manner.
I could barely put it
into words in that moment.
All I might have thought
in my head was pedophile,
pedophile and um, you know, like grabbed
her and like usher her through the aisle.
And I didn't have confidence at that point
to like say something cause I didn't,
I always like second guessing myself.
Am I correct? You know, is that right?
What can I say? Like I think there's
a weird guy and I'll fight and five,
like what do you tell people?
Knowing what I know now,
I would've gone back in
time and I would've gone to
the front desk or whatever
and said, there's a really
sketchy guy in aisle five.
He looks like a pedophile to me. But
you know, just letting you know. Um,
but it's, so, it's interesting
because I noticed something,
I was paying attention to
something that didn't look right.
And so I think you really have to honor
your gut feeling when something is out
of place. And the more you pay
attention to your surroundings and more,
you'll see things that just don't
fit in or just don't look right and,
and you'll be surprised.
Yeah. That makes sense. Um,
last question and then we'll
move on to audience questions.
What's most valuable lesson that you
learned at CIA that might be applicable to
everyone, including us,
civilians? So it really kind of,
it's the theme of today,
which is
you have to find a weak way in your
job to be authentically who you are.
It takes a long period of time to build
up the confidence to say, how can I,
with my unique perspective,
bring who I am to this job or this role?
And to have the confidence to say I
see things a little bit differently.
Can we potentially do this or that?
And what's nice is Google,
you worked for a company that really
honors innovation and you work in a place
that kind of upholds that, which
is fabulous. Like I'm jealous.
Um,
but the idea is to not,
is to feel free to disrupt
because of who you are.
Use your personality to
disrupt the status quo,
to innovate,
to change how things are done.
Your power comes in your authenticity.
When I tried to run an operation
like my male colleagues,
I wasn't doing a very good job.
But when I decided in that
moment I'm going to be Michelle,
my Smiley Michelle face, whatever
that seemed so foreign to the CIA.
But when I brought that into into my
job and brought it into the way that I
planned and executed operations,
I stood out in the best possible way.
And I,
I what made me feel initially like an odd
ball in this day is what enabled me to
shine eventually. And again, it took
me like five years to figure that out.
And hopefully it won't take you as long,
but it is to encourage you
to be as authentic in what
you do every day because I
think that's where your
success lies. Yeah. Oh yeah.
Say the question is what do I think about
what's going on in terms of terrorism
in the Middle East and there is it
getting better or worse? So, um,
we've done a pretty good job of disrupting
isis from its stronghold in Syria and
northern Iraq, as you all know.
Um, there's no longer a caliphate,
although there are pockets of Isis in
northern Iraq and obviously still in Syria
now what the press is not
telling you very much.
I think there's just been
little glimpses of it.
This is the big insight right here.
A lot of the leadership that hasn't been
killed in counterterrorism operations
is in Libya.
I think Libya is going to be the next
Afghanistan in terms of a base of
operations.
Um,
and so I think because
Libya is essentially, uh,
hardly functioning country, it's
a, it's Olivia as you can tell is,
is a mass.
There is a government,
but the government has very little
control over what happens all over Libya.
And so things are going
haywire in the country,
which is why you have people smugglers
and crime syndicates sending migrants
across the Mediterranean into Europe.
And now I think that the more
that terrorism leadership
sets up base in Libya,
the more you're going to see a marriage
of terrorism and the human smuggling
trade,
which is very lucrative in terms of
lining their pockets and helping them,
um, kind of re constituent,
uh, recalibrate,
reconstitute themselves.
And so I'd say heads heads up on Libya.
You mentioned earlier
getting the motivation behind
why individuals are doing
what they're doing. And one of them struck
me was to eliminate the competition.
Yes. Um, what kind of terrorist
competition is dinner?
Yeah. I let you know. This
is interesting actually.
So it took me a long while to figure
this out, but there were a lot of,
a lot of sources who pretended
like they were all like,
oh yeah, CIA, we're friends, we're good.
We're going to work together. When in a,
in effect, they had never intended
to leave terrorism behind.
They just wanted to take out the other
guy in the block so they could be in
charge.
So it's like a double agent,
but not in order to work
against CIA necessarily,
but a double agent to establish
their power on the street.
So they'd be like, Hey, that guy over
there, he's a really bad terrorist.
His name is so and so.
This is his phone number.
This is make and model of his car and
this is the location of his safe house.
Next thing you know, ca or not, Eh,
military troops, uh, take out
that guy. Next thing you know,
we find out a year later we took out
the competition then that that guy took
over as head Honcho and was playing us.
Essentially.
That happened more often
than we'd like to admit.
Here's my Herdman.
Uh,
so imagine that there are many
sources who are coming to you,
but in my case that you're
reaching out. Like how do you, uh,
how are you finding the people that are
the best sources and then how do you
train them into sources of names?
It's tricky because so much of that
I'm not allowed to talk about. Um,
I can say,
cause this was cleared for my buck.
People think it's so hard
to recruit sources. Um,
and there's certain things
and intelligence like it's
hard to recruit a North
Korean cause it's hard to find them.
It's um, it's hard to recruit, uh,
Putin's inner circle for obvious reasons.
It's not hard to recruit
in the Middle East,
especially for counterterrorism
operations. It's not hard
to collect information.
What is really hard as
collecting good information.
Most of what we get as
fabrications or lies.
And so the better we are at vetting
the information and finding the golden
nuggets, the better. You know, that's,
that's the hard part of the job. And,
and recruiting people who are being truly
recruited versus using you to take out
the competition. That's also the
hard part. It's like a half answer.
How do you like that one?
Um, you were talking a little bit about
developing those instincts for spotting
things that you feel are off.
Um,
we have programs running here are Rhonda
becoming more aware of your unconscious
biases and how those
can be really damaging.
It's not something that you may cut
a potentially really damaging news.
They're not based,
they're based in unconscious bias rather
than it's kind of back. So I'm curious,
I'm not, as we were developing
those instincts that,
how did you differentiate between what
might be bias on the basis of how we're
socialized,
you know,
broadly and where you found that your
instincts were really right and how you,
how you sort of be those determined?
Gosh. Oh, that's a good question. I mean,
was it in terms of understanding my own
biases are understanding theirs. Mine.
Okay. Um, yeah,
because we all bring biases to
the job. Absolutely. All of us.
And I think it's impossible to
completely like, Eh, we're human beings.
We're flawed. Um, but I think
the extent to which you can
call it out and I,
I think there's some level of emotional
intelligence involved in that, you know,
and being aware of yourself, some
people just aren't aware. Um, and,
and that's where a dialogue and debate
with others can be helpful to you,
you know, healthy dialogue to help us each
understand our and things. So, I mean,
I had to be,
if I'm going to deal with this guy,
you know, my natural, actually
this is funny, this is not,
I would say my natural
inclination was to not trust,
but that's actually a good
thing in intelligence. Um,
so in that case it worked,
but in, in real life, outside of
intelligence, not trusting anyone as,
as a hard way to live her life. But I
don't know if that answers your question.
You're gonna make me think
about that for a while,
not sticking around.
And that's are kind of internally
focused that he really good at.
What are you doing,
gutting it out there?
Any ways or do you have any thoughts
about ways to kind of more directly
addressed some of the obstacles
that you faced in your career?
Great question.
One of the things that I did,
because I had to find ways to show that
expertise. So you're like, yeah, okay,
become really good at what you
do and then what? And so, uh,
for a long period of time in the CIA
I was really jealous of a lot of my
classmates that getting
sent to really nice places.
I read it now,
I'm like,
I can't tell you where they
were eating great food and
they were classical architecture and
nobody's shooting at though. And um,
my husband and I felt like we kept
getting the shaft because, okay,
one more zone to war zones,
but really 10 years of that and um,
we kept doing the jobs
no one else wanted to do.
And part of that was okay,
we were Airbus. Okay.
There's a reason why you keep getting
sent to these places because that's where
a lot of the conflict is going
on in this moment of time.
It took me looking back at my CIA career
to realize by taking the jobs no one
else wanted to do,
we had developed this level of terrorism
expertise that I would sit with my
classmates back at CIA headquarters when
I was on on a TDY and they would listen
to my story stories if my meetings
with terrorists and be like,
I have nothing to relate to that
I've never done anything like that.
I realize by getting shaft and getting
shafted over and over again was actually
a career builder.
And so I also realized that by taking a
couple of the projects that no one else
wanted to do, jasmine and I talked
about this last night a little bit.
She did something similar.
Um,
and sometimes you don't know somebody has
given you like the project no one else
wants.
Um,
there were a couple of occasions
when I did that and I said like,
I kind of show my skills and
so I found some ways to like,
do these projects tend to be
unique and creative and different.
And when I actually handed it back
to the manager, they were like, well,
what is that? You actually did? You did
do the project. I'm like, well yeah,
you gave it to me. I did it. Um,
so there's some thing about doing the
things others don't want and knocking the
ball out of the park. I don't
know. There's something to
be said in that strategy.
I know that's not the only strategy,
but it worked.
That's one strategy that worked for me.
So you're talk, uh,
you mentioned that, um,
as a female and he smiled and
people were thinking that.
And I'm especially in
Washington DC as long as all,
and sometimes you only use the, with
people briefly. So how was your strategy?
Right,
the worst question,
I think it's really impossible to do.
If you have a really short
interaction with someone,
they're probably going to still walk
away from you after a five minute meeting
or a two minute meeting or an
introduction thinking when they walked in.
So I think in order to change people's
minds, you have to have some time.
You have to have some history
with them. Um, you know,
I figured out how to make it work and
there's debriefings cause it had to happen
really, really quickly, but that was a
very artificial compressed period of time.
Like we just had to get in that
room and get down to business.
But that was unusual.
I think that often
I'm not a person that feels comfortable
being like, yeah, I'm smart.
Yeah,
I,
I don't,
I'm not one of those people that feels
comfortable like trying to self promote.
I don't like self promotion,
but I think in some cases you have to
find some subtle way to do that that might
be against your nature
in order to survive.
Hi. It's very nice. It
is the CIA, CIA today.
Is it your friend and know when you
joined or did it change in there?
I did, I don't know for sure. Cause
I, um, when you leave the CIA,
you can only take,
stay in touch with people who reach out
to you because you don't want to blow
their cover. And so it's very
tricky about who you talk to.
And so it's not like I'm
still in touch with everyone.
So I am surmising that privately nothing
has changed just because I've talked.
Was that, does that diplomatic enough? Um,
just because I talked to women and men
who served like in the 1980s and I hear
the same stories and so nothing's changed
since 1982 it probably hasn't changed
in the six years since I left agency.
And 2003 the war was stolen.
Two allies,
public art on the basis of
information about by us.
Yes.
To what extent did you feel pressured to
develop information that's important to
be the point of view and it's,
we're expanded your calendar that,
yes. So, um,
we were there when that always happening
because we were just baby intelligence
officers.
And so there was a efforts to try to
find this elusive information that just
didn't exist. Um, you just have,
there was a situation when my husband's
boss changed a report to reflect
something that didn't actually happen
in the meeting and he stood up and said
that's not what happened in the meeting.
And that information was of
such a consequential nature.
It was going to end up in front of
the president in the White House.
My husband basically got nixed on his
annual performance because he stood up to
his boss and said that
that never happened.
So when I say the CIA is a
hostile work environment,
that's the kind of
thing I'm talking about.
So you have a decision like are you going
to do the right thing if it means that
your setback in your career, um, or
are you just going to tow the line?
I wouldn't, but just to be
fair, that guy was very unusual.
I hope to never work with
someone like that. Again,
I didn't see that in other places.
I just saw that with that particular
individual. A lot of fabrication going on.
But it's a, it's a very,
I wish that on no one,
cause that's such a hard place to
such an awful place to be really.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah,
right. Another question. Uh, just keeping
your husband, it's obviously you, the CIO,
yours.
Um,
we see movies all the time
and I'm sure you know,
movies like we watch hacking and nobody
is this like on bypassing the fingers
right hand.
That's cool.
Eyes Roll back.
Yeah.
Um,
how often,
how true is it in your life where you
weren't allowed to tell your extended
family what you actually did it or where
you were, what like did where you, uh,
were you,
did you have a cover story for back home?
Okay. So, um, it was
really interesting. So it,
as we're going through that CII
recruitment process, the recruiter said,
be careful who you tell about the process
you're going through right now because
you can't,
you can't tell your 50 friends that you're
applying to the CIA and you're going
through this process and then
suddenly, er, no, I'm just kidding.
Then they also, once we got
into this day and we got hired,
you are allowed to tell your immediate
family but only if you think they can
handle it. Um, and so
there are some people,
like I had a colleague in Baghdad whose
family thought she was working on her
phd in the United States.
They had no idea she worked
for CIA government. I'm like,
how do you keep that cover
story writing were like eight,
nine hour time difference.
How do you to that?
I don't think she hardly ever
talked to her family. Um,
there were people who is like,
yeah,
if I tell my mom she's going
to shout it from the rooftops,
she seemed like my is so awesome.
She works for the CIA.
Or there's somebody who's like,
my dad's going to be watching the evening
news every night thinking he's going
to see my face on there
and he can't handle it.
So you have to make this a c because
they now have to protect your cover story
when you tell them and they have to do
it conveniently convincingly for you.
And if you pick up the phone
and you call him and they say,
how are things at the CIA,
they blown your cover.
So you have to be absolutely certain
that the few people that you do tall
understand that your life
is on the line and they,
they've got to protect you.
Um,
my husband's family because
he's originally from Egypt,
were not American citizens and so we
never told them because we didn't want to
put them in danger.
Um,
I think towards the end of
our career before they passed,
I think they suspected that
something else was going on. And I,
and I think they were proud of my husband,
which makes them feel good now,
but he was never actually
able to tell them.
I think at one point he said to his
dad like a month before he passed away,
you know,
dad,
I've been doing counter terrorism
work and he goes, I know,
just shake his head like that. And
so I think you've figured it out. But
yeah, an interesting question.
Um, there is fun. Rather
they read return on it.
If they can make a magic
wand and have a good night
to create this caliphate,
which they thought they were creating
and Syria where they could control this
whole new, um, uh, Ma, uh,
the body of believers,
this political religious state firmly
grounded on their interpretation of Sharia
law. And of course the guys that are
terrorists really want this to be,
you know,
the woman doesn't leave the home uncovered
and the men's are men are warriors
and you give people a choice to
convert to Islam or die like, so their,
their interpretation of Islam
is what you see on the TV.
And in their perfect world there,
their idea of
perfection is this,
this caliphate really.
Yeah. And, and,
and the caliphate then being used to then
spread Islam to the rest of the world
and specifically their interpretation of
Islam and, and, and, uh, bringing that,
uh,
either by missionary efforts or force.
So would you say that in some
ways they're idealists? Yes,
absolutely.
I have a question about what is the
reason make you leave CIA and it was New
York cons. Uh, how do your
things, your cons, um,
commuter life compare
when was snowing there?
Um,
so after 10 years of war
zones and working weekends,
working holidays,
I'm not seeing your family except maybe
once a year for a couple of weeks being
undercover,
working in places where you're constantly
looking for hostile surveillance.
Cause we were in places where there were
car jackings and kidnappings and Alcott
it was running around.
So it was like this really intense
and hard way to live. We're,
Joseph and I are constantly looking at,
somebody's got an AK 47
or an RPG aimed at us.
You just, it's not
sustainable. That lifestyle.
And we work saw stud.
And I'm also at the same time I felt this
spiritual calling to write this book.
And I knew that in order to do,
to help inspire others with my story,
I had to do it in true
name versus pseudonym,
which meant I'd have to leave the CIA and
I'd have to request permission to drop
cover, which is a big deal and
they don't have to do it. So,
um, after 10 years we left and I
actually started writing this book, um,
breaking cover when I was a
year before I left the agency.
And now I feel so free.
Nobody's trying to shoot me most of the
time anyway, right? Like, um, I, I, yeah,
I in the United States is
still a dangerous place and
all, but it's, it's a, it's,
it's very different than what our
former lives where the fact that,
um, that I can be sharing these
stories with you gives me intense,
a lot of joy to share my
stories and inspire others.
And so I could not be
happier at the moment.
It was very public events,
uh,
affect your ability to build trust
with their contacts then, uh,
figure don't believe
you didn't do your job.
Um,
public events like speaking events,
very public events like
Benghazi and then use,
oh, sorry, sorry. Um, how
do those events affect you,
your ability to, uh, to like
develop that trust you need.
Got It. You know, it's really hard
to tell your sources these days.
Trust me,
your name will never get leaked.
I think there's just been so many leaks,
so much classified information has
come out and it's made our jobs.
I can tell you every time there was a
leak and we were still working at the CIA,
we had all kinds of sources
quit left and right because I'm,
once those names were late,
people were, was lives.
They either had to get out of
dodge or they were killed. Um,
so it is very hard these days to recruit
new sources because we can't really,
I can do everything I can to protect
you, but I can't help who, you know,
what other people do. So it's hard. Yeah.
So let me get this picture of
the CIA as a bureaucratic boy,
number three guy down or eat rigorous
in their determination of what we've
always done it this way.
Yeah. And at the same time,
the tourist organization or something
like the Westboro Baptist Church speaks
copy up. Are there any upsides? I mean,
this doesn't look like a recipe for any
sort of improvement you do long term.
Yeah. Um, I think that this, the CIA,
there are a lot of,
there are a lot of good people at the
CIA that I succeed and protect us every
single day despite this
bureaucratic organization
that is still living like it's
1960. Um, I, I,
we kind of need some serious strategic
and visionary leadership to change that.
I don't see that happening.
I really don't. I, I'm, I'm
a realist in that regard.
Usually I'm an optimist,
but I've been in long enough to realize
it's probably not going to happen. Um,
but I think that the world changed so
much and we're still pretending like we're
in a cold war and we haven't adjusted
the way that we carried out operations to
the new realities that we're dealing with.
So I think that we're not doing as
good a job. America deserves better.
Um, I don't know how to get us
there, but even having these talks,
I hope in some way will influence some
people to join who are going to be
visionary people in the future and maybe
bring some something new and fresh to
the CIA.
What are your thoughts on Edward
Snowden's actions and what you reveal?
Um,
he put a lot of people
and sources and in danger.
So I don't have a very
high opinion of Mr Snowden.
Let's just put it that
a lot of the programs that he,
uh,
he talked about were not secret secret
programs in the sense that they weren't
this, um, they were, um,
coordinated amongst all of the
entities in Washington that have
oversight over intelligence.
So it wasn't like a rogue, they
weren't rogue programs in that regard.
The way that the media
makes it sound does this,
they were the NSA and
its own rogue program,
but you have congressional oversight
and you have this oversight and that
oversight. So they were,
um, these programs were,
uh, as I understand it,
properly coordinated, but
he relieves so much other,
he really so much information that was
so damaging to our relationships with our
allies abroad.
You mean almost all week.
All of our ambassadors had
to have meetings after that
where they basically were
told by the, um, the president or
minister of Interior that country. Like,
we can't trust you people.
You guys can't keep anything a secret,
and so we're not going to
tell you secrets anymore.
So our counter terrorism fight
us, suffered our, our, um,
ability to work with our foreign powers
on law enforcement and migration issues
has suffered a great deal because right.
That stuff,
is there any sense of responsibility
for if we weren't spying on Americans?
Um, then you get into the details
of the, is it, is it spying?
It's metadata collection.
Then how are you using it and all of that
stuff.
Um,
yeah, I mean, cause, uh, then
then the question would be, um,
to the oversight committees. You thought
that was okay, but now we're telling you,
or if you disagree with that,
then there's a debate about should we
be doing this or not? Yeah. I mean,
this was a delight.
Thank you for coming here and
sharing your experience with us.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.